よろしくお願いします
今日は心の次の次元で今次元を2つ説明してまいりました
色界の次元 あるいは欲界の次元という三次元的な世界と
それからそれを超えている色界という次元ですね
仏教で三次元という次元には
普通に一般常識で言っている天界も入るんです
そこら辺ちょっと理解してほしいんです
で まあ人間より優れているレベルに生活している神々やらね
まあいろんな概念は世の中で一般的にあるし
それも人々はただ単に自分の感覚で観念で言っているわけでもなくて
いろいろそういう経験があったり
いろいろコンタクトがあったりとかして
神々の存在もあると思っているし
単なる感覚で あればいいという感じで言っている人々も多くいますけど
それはどうでもいいんですけど
一般的に世の中で言っている神々という神という次元も
仏教では欲界に入っているんですね
で それより優れている次元なんでね
色界っていうのは それは梵天と特別な言葉で使っているし
梵天という言葉はまたヒンドゥー教バラモン教で
ヒンドゥゥ教でも出ている言葉ですけど
なぜわざわざなぜその言葉を使ったかというと
バラモン教あるいはヒンドゥー教においては
梵天 梵というのは一番最高たる次元なんですね
で いわゆる心はほとんど清らかになっている次元なんですね
その定義は仏教でも認めているんですね
心清らかになったところで梵天になるんだということは
ですから仏教でもその清らかなという意味で優れているという意味でブラフマという言葉を使って
ブラフマとかって梵天という次元があります
その仏教の梵天という次元はまた2つに分けて
今まで説明したのは色界という梵天の次元なんですね
だから色界に入るためにはやっぱり瞑想しなくちゃいけない
その考え方は まあまたヒンドゥー教でも同じく
梵天を体験するために
梵という状態を体現するためには
ヨーガというヨーガというのは瞑想という意味で瞑想しなくちゃいけないし
心を清らかにしなくちゃいけないし
そうでないと決して得られる状態ではないんですね
ごく普通の宗教的な仕来りやっても
梵が知る状態にはならないんですね
そのところはヒンドゥー教でも同じことを言っているんですね
例えばヨーガ ヴェーダを唱えたり
法魔という護摩ですね
日本語でいう法魔を称えたり
歌いたりしたっても 儀式ぎりやっても梵が一人になれないんだと
それにはウパニシャッドという哲学で言っているようなことで
自我を何ですかと体験しなくちゃいけないということで
瞑想しなくちゃいけないんですね
そこら辺でも似ているんですね
で 似ているのはごく普通なことで
なぜならばお釈迦様も仏教を発見する前に
ごく普通の行者たちと一緒にみんなと一緒に修行していたんですね
ですから お釈迦様もこの最高なレベルまで
バラモン教で言っている最高なレベルのところまで心を育てていたんですね
それからそれは意味がないんだと
それは悟りでも解脱でも何でもないんだと思って
そこから離れたんですね
ですから お釈迦様の最初の先生でした
このウッダカ・ラームプッタというものすごい偉大なる仙人で
で 彼のところで勉強して
ほんの2 3週間で全部終わったんですね
勉強は 勉強終わったところで修行なさって
この先生はこんなにものすごい超次元的な超自然的な知恵を持っているんだ
それは単なる知識で合理的で喋っているわけじゃないんだと
だから私もやってみようと思ったところで
まっすぐ 1日でその最高たる禅定状態を得たんです
で 先生に報告したんで
先生おっしゃっているのはこういうこういう境地ですかと
言われたら先生驚いちゃって
これはすごい珍しいことだと
この世の中で人間ってなかなかそんな境地に至るわけがないんだと
やっぱりまさに私が得ている心の境地もあなたも得ているんだと
あなた得ている境地には私も至っているんだと
ですから 今日からはあなたは私の弟子じゃないんだと
なぜならば あなたも私も全く同じですよ
ですから これから人々に教えてあげなさいと
一緒になって協力してくださいと言われたら
だからそれはインド文化では褒め言葉の中で最高の褒め言葉なんですね
先生は弟子を自分と同じ位に入れて
あなたも私も同じですよと言われること
お釈迦様も同じ言葉で自分の弟子たちを褒めているんですね
例えば悟ったところで
阿羅漢になったならば
時にその言葉は 1箇所しか出てきませんだけど
6人の阿羅漢たち出たところで
みんな集めて あなた方は全ての煩悩から解脱しました
私も全ての煩悩から解脱しましたと
ですから この人々のために
人間の幸福のために いろんなところに歩き回って
この悟りの知恵の道を教えてくださいと紹介してくださいと弟子たちをあちこち行かせるんですね
ですから お釈迦様も自分は悟る前の自分の先生と同じことをやっているんだけど
違うところは お釈迦様の昔の先生は 1箇所に泊まって
そこで弟子を入れてもらって
使って修行していたんだけど
お釈迦様はそうではなくても自分で歩くんですね
あっちこっちで弟子たちにもあっちこっち歩きなさいと
別室 1箇所にとどまって
何か教会みたいなものを作ったりしてね
そういうふうな感じではなくて
自由に歩き回って喋ってくださいということでやっていらっしゃったんですけど
ですから この 心を超越して
そのレベルを体験したっていうことは
インド文化で遠い昔はあったことで
今はそんなにないんですけどね
昔はもういろいろあったみたいですね
だからその中でも珍しい先生二人がいて
その先生二人からお釈迦様はヨーガ的な瞑想法を教えてもらったんですね
現代あるヨーガっていうのは
それから出て その古い伝統ではないんですね
ヒンドゥー教は死にかけたところで
新しい宗教からまた勉強し直して
直して 現代我々にあるヒンドゥー教できてますからね
それはすごい新しい宗教システムなんですね
昔やったバラモン教とお釈迦様であった宗教は今存在していないんです
ですから お釈迦様もやっぱりヒンドゥー教
バラモン教 ものすごく堕落しているんだとすごく悩んでいたというか
みんなに批判していたんですね
バラモン寺 あんた方何やってるんですか？と
昔の森林たちってのはそれ優れていたのではないか
あるところであんた方は犬にも与えないほど呼ばれているんだと
犬の方がマシだよというぐらいきつい言葉まで言ってるんですね
でもバラモン教批判した否定したことはあまりないんですけどね
森林たちが素晴らしい森林たちであることはちゃんと認めているんですね
で そこでなぜ仏教が違いますかということはこれから理解できますけどね
で それでこの今日まずこんな同じ話を何回も繰り返して繰り返して申し上げてますけど
世の中でみんな言ってる神々という概念は
仏教では欲界の概念であって
どんな人間でもいい生活していれば
罪を犯さないで 悪いことをしないで
ごく普通に立派な人間で生きていれば
死んじゃったらもう簡単に天国に行けるんですよ
必死で苦労苦労しなくても
で 天国に行く方法なんですか？と聞いたら
お釈迦様も五戒ぐらい守って
殺生しないでね 自分得る収入をみんなと分けて食べて
もう家族をちゃんと大事にして生活すれば
みんな天国に行きますよと
すごい簡単に扱ってるんですね
でも色界に行くのはそんな簡単なもんじゃないので
それはもう厳しい修行は必要とするんですね
色界と梵天であって その辺でヒンドゥー教でも言ってる
この瞑想して修行してヨーガをやってヨーガを体験して得るものなんですね
で それからこの色界の説明はすごく詳しくしたと思いますが
瞑想する場合は何か対象を取って
その対象に集中するんですね
それは普段普通にはやらないことで
我々は例えば本持ったら
本をずっといかに早く読めるかということで勝負なんですね
ですから 普通の人間というのは
ある一つのものにずっと集中するって
それは人間にとってはつまらないことだと思ってるんですね
人間というのは瞬時にいろんなものを知りたがっちゃうんです
いわゆる激しく心を荒波を立てたがっちゃうんですね
その方が面白いんだと
瞑想の違うところはそうじゃなくて
この知識の機能はそのままストップするんですね
で 例えば壁見ていると
知識で壁見ていると 壁はどれぐらい大きいですか
どんな傷跡があるんですか？あるんですか？どんな色を塗ってるんですかとか
その壁の塗ってるペンキはどんなものですかとか
そういうふうなきめ細かく見る
詳しく見る それは知識的な見方
それにはいろいろ言葉
概念が必要なんですね
他の知識も必要なんですね
それはレンガで建て作ってる壁か
あるいはベニヤ板で張ってる板作っている壁ですか？あるいは壁紙張ってるんで
壁紙はどこにどこで作ったものですかとか
知識が必要なんですね
我々は それはすごい明確にその人は壁を見ているんではないかと
詳しいやと思っちゃうんですね
それは欲界の働きで じゃあ知識を乗り越えて壁をどう見ますかというと
何のこともなく壁を目を開けて見ているんです
全ての言葉を止める 考え方を止める
止めて じゃあ見ている
見ていると壁から何かの情報を耳目に触れる
この触れる情報だけ認識する
そこに概念はないんです
壁という概念もない それは頭が作るんですね
壁ですよと ですから色界の瞑想する場合は
大体何か色を見て瞑想するとか
いろいろ瞑想法ありますから
そういう風に 例えば仏教で言ってる瞑想というのは慈悲の瞑想と色界の瞑想なんですけど
たとえ何の概念もなく
ただ生きとし生けるものは幸せでありますようにと
それ考えないんです 単なる一つの幸せでありますように
幸せって何ですかと考えません
ただ単に 例えば自分にとっては幸せでありますようにというのは
ただ何か分からないんだけど
いいことなんですね なってほしいこと
それだけで十分なんです
それで全ての生命が幸福でありますように
生命が幸福でありますように
そればっかり念じてるんです
そうするとどうなるかというと
この知識の働きはどんどんどんどん働かなくなっちゃうんですね
だからこの難しいところは
もう知識的にずっと頑張ってるんだから
その状態から知識は機能しない状態に移転する
この間っていうのはすごい修行はきついんです
英語で言えばトランジションピーストランジションなんですね
転換の だから誰にでも誰でも瞑想やりたがらないというか
やっても難しいとか厳しいとか
やりにくいとかいろいろあるのは
心が知識の領域に戻りたくて戻りたくて必死で行動する
慣れてるんだから そちらの方が居心地が良くて
知識じゃない 何も考えてない状態
思っただけでも怖くなっちゃうんですね
危ないんではないかと
物事考えてなくてはいけないんではないかと怖くなったりするんですね
バカになるんではないかとか
人々としゃべれなくなっちゃうんではないかと
そういうすべては欲界にいたいいたいという言葉なんですね
人としゃべれない しゃべれなくなるんではないかと思っちゃったら
この人はどうせ当たり前で人々と喋って仲良くしたい
それだったら色界はもう無理なんですね
いわゆる日本は恋しくて
日本からは離れられなくて
自分を知ってる人々から徹底的に執着して
それでも外国旅行したいと言っても
それは無理なんです 外国に行きたければ
こちらにある執着をやめて向こうに執着をしなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから この瞑想の難しいところは
やっぱり我々は欲界の世界に
この現に比率の世界に大変囚われていて
だから瞑想を始めたら
もう本当は大変簡単な方法なんですけどね
何も難しいことがなく
すっごいものすごい楽な方法なんです
で 遊ぶよりも楽しいんです
どんなごちそうを食べるよりも
こちらの方が気持ちいいんです
わずかな難しさもないんです
でも 人間は修行によってすごい厳しさ感じちゃうんです
それはもう修行悪いんじゃなくて
人間が悪いだけなんですね
自分たちがそれをやりたくない色界に
なんか欲界の中にいたいんだから
ですから このたとえ壁見ようとしたら
ただ見ている見ているだけで
それ見ているんです あれは見えてる見えてるとかね
そこで何か一つだけの情報を認識の世界に入って入って
その波がどんどん消えていっちゃうんですね
荒波が で 荒波が消えていって一体になると言うかね
この存在の基本的な状態になるということはなるんですね
そうするとこの壁と自分は一つになったような感じがする
それは色界の第一番目の禅定なんですね
で その時はもう何か自分はいるという感じがあるんだけど
もう自分と主体と客体っていうのは差がなくなっちゃうんですね
だから自分という特別な存在
個体としていないということを感じることは
ものすごい究極的な喜びなんです
ですから このヨーガの世界でも
この心理状態になったらサッチット
アーナンダとリアリティーと
そこにチット 心 あるいはアートマンがあって
アーナンダ至福ありますよという 3つのグナですか
特色があるんだと言ってるんですね
それはもう全くその通りで
瞑想して この一体感というものを感じると
ものすごい喜悦感というものは感じちゃう
今まで人と喋って遊んでご飯食べて服を着て
いろんなところに行って楽しがっていたんだけど
あれはすごい苦しみではなかったという風に
そちらに対する あの 何と言いますか
執着はもう結構もう消えてしまう
もう面白くなくなっちゃうんです
で そこであの 第1禅定に入るためには
五蓋という 5つの邪魔なものがございます
その邪魔なものは抑えなくちゃいけない
それ五蓋というのはカーマッチャンダ
ヴェーパーナ ティーナミッダ
ウッダッチクッチャ ヴィチキッチャと5つなんですね
カーマッチャンダというのは欲望とヴェーパーナというのは瞋恚たりと
えーと ティーナミッダっていうのは昏沈睡眠とウッダッチクッチャっていうのは掉挙と後悔ですね
それからヴィチキッチャ
疑なんですね で その 5つはこの仏教では煩悩と言ってるし
で 瞑想では まあその瞑想成功するためには
この 5つをとにかく抑えなくちゃいけないんですね
その煩悩は何に過ぎてありますか？と
この欲界に対してあるんですね
だから欲望というのは
見たり聞いたり味わったりしたいという気持ちがある
だから瞑想したくない
で 昏沈睡眠も体を楽しみたい
楽にしたい 怠けたいという気持ちだから
それも欲界の働きで欲界に誘惑されてるんですね
欲界に引っ張られてるんで
5つのエネルギーで その 5つのエネルギーを消えた瞬間で消えてくると
瞑想どんどんしやすくなってきて
さらにそれは抑えてしまっちゃったら
機能しなくなくなっちゃったら
すぐ第一禅定状態が生まれてくる
その状態では まあ一体感がありまして
至福感がありますと それ色界の世界なんですね
そこで第一禅定では大体人々
それでも一体感があっても
人の思考が働いてるんです
で 何か見ているんですね
そこでさらに進んじゃうと
思考も止まってしまう
もう考えることなくなっちゃう
いわゆる心の波が消えちゃう
で それが第二禅定からなんですね
それ第四禅定っていうのは至福感だけ生まれて
すごい楽しみさと至福感だけ
ある で 第五の番目の禅定っていうのは
この楽しい楽しいということもなく
ものすごい落ち着いて冷静な状態になる
だから一体感は一体感なんです
一体感であって 一番初めはこの壁を見ていたならば
壁と自分が一致するようになったことだから
それはさらに進んでって壁とかなんとかではなくて
なんかすごい落ち着いて
なんか波が立たないように落ち着いて冷静にな
心のレベルが生まれてくるんですね
その体験というのは その長い時間は続かないんです
肉体を持ってるんだから
すぐ心は元に戻るんですね
元に戻っても もう欲界に対しては未練がないんですね
欲界でももう食べなくちゃいけないんだけど
食べるんだけど そんなものは別に本物じゃないと
その楽しみは本物じゃないということはもう分かっているんですね
ですから また二度とその禅定に入りたいと思ったら簡単に入るんです
で そこで何回も何回も繰り返し繰り返し繰り返し繰り返し
一つの禅定に何回も入らなくちゃいけないんですね
入ってどれぐらい長い時間いられるかと
自分の心のエネルギーを試さなくちゃいけないんですね
それからまず時間決めて
じゃあ今度は二分間 二分間その状態でいてみますよと
で 頑張った それで二分間できたところで
まあ今度は五分間いてみますよとか
そこで三十分一時間ぐらいできれば
もう最高にこの瞑想状態は自分の身についたというんですね
そこでそれできたらすぐ入る
瞑想状態に入るためには時間がかかるんですね
慣れた人にしても そこですぐ入ること
例えば一時間瞑想したところで
やっと禅定に入ったという人は
もう一時間後控えて じゃあ五十分で入ってみます
もう四十分ぐらいで入ってみようと
もっと真剣に瞑想をまたやり直したりして
それでまあできるだけ時間短くして座ってすぐ禅定に入るようにする
それから長い時間いられるようにする
それからもっと自己コントロールするんですね
例えば瞬時に瞑想に入って
希望した時間 長くするか短くするかと
それも例えば一時間ぐらいいられるならば
大体禅定に入ったら その力でずっと禅定にいて自然に禅定は切れちゃうんですね
切れて普通の心に戻るんですね
その禅定のエネルギーが切られちゃったら
そうしないで自分で切る
例えば一時間でもいられる
一時間では自然に切れる
それもじゃあ三十分で止まる
二十分で止まる 一時間で一分で止まるとか
そういう瞬時に自分希望したところで禅定状態をカットして普通に戻ると
そういうふうなこの禅定の状態について様々な訓練しなくちゃいけないんですね
それはパンチャシータとかいう専門用語がございますけど
五つの訓練 種類の訓練があるので
僕は今五つも説明しましたけど
で そういうふうにこの禅定を訓練してくださいと仏教で特別に言ってるんです
そこら辺はもしかするとヨーガの世界で
ヒンドゥー教の世界であるかどうかは分かりません
で 仏教のテキストでは
たった入っただけでありがたいなんでもなくて
また何回も何回も入れるか
同じ状態の境地に入れるかどうか試してみろとかね
何回何回入ってみるとか
時間伸ばしてみる 希望して希望通りにいくかないか見てみるとかね
それから瞑想終わったら
禅定から立ち上がったらすぐこの観察するということもやらなくちゃ
それはもう特別に仏教で厳密にやらなくちゃいけないことなんですね
仏教の人がヨーガやるならば
必ずしもその後の観察っていうものは
このパッチャヴェッカナと言うんです
それはパーリ語で パッチャヴェッカナというものをしなくちゃいけないんですね
で まあ正しいを書けばパッチャヴェッカナなんですけど
このパッチャヴェッカナということはしなくちゃいけないんですね
パッチャというのはアフター
あと アヴェッカティという言葉なんですね
オブザーブ 観察する 禅定に入ってそれから終わってから
それを観察するということで
いわゆるそこは大変仏教においては大事なことなんです
仏教では他の宗教の修行法を一つも否定してないんです
修行は宗教は悪いことを教えてないんだから
心 心底っていうのはどんな宗教でも言ってるんだから
それにはケチつける必要はないんです
キリスト教にしたってもね
ものすごいもう生命に優しく
欲が少なく 頑張りなさいというふうなことを言ってるんだからね
そこは決して悪いことじゃないんですよ
悪いこと 悪いことをおっしゃってるわけじゃないんです
ですから このそれにケチつけるわけじゃなくて
この仏教の人でも他の瞑想を試してみたって
それは別に悪いことではないし
で 問題は仏教でいうのはこのパッチャヴェッカナしなさいと
いわゆる禅定に入って禅定終わった
終わったら自分がどういう境地にいたか
それはどういうものかと後から客観的に見てみなさいと
それはしないと執着するんですね
吸い込まれるんですね
これこそやと思っちゃうんです
自分が究極的な境地に至ったんだと
すごい勘違いするんですね
そこを怠りますから まあみんな無茶苦茶なんですね
この瞑想っていうのは心を統一することであるならば
どんな人間瞑想したっても同じ法則ですから
心の法則は 同じく育てるはずなんですよ
瞑想にはいろいろな道があるはずがないんです
仏教は科学的に見ているんだから
心理学的に見ているんだから
心の成長っていうのは同じであるはずなんです
でも 世の中にある瞑想っていうのはそんなことではないんですね
方法は色々あるのは それはまた別に問題ないんだけど
どんな方法でも同じ境地に至らなくちゃいけないんです
カルマヨーガであろうとも
バクティヨーガであろうとも
ハタヨーガであろうとも
それ関係なくラージヨーガであろうとも
同じ境地を体験しなくちゃいけないんですね
でもそうでもないんですね
人々の神秘体験は説明してくださいと言ったら
もう自分なりの体験はそれぞれ違っていて
その人の人は自分たちが究極的な境地に至っているんだと考えているんですね
ですから それ自分の経験だから違いますよとは他人には言えないんですね
本人が体験したものだから
例えば私がご飯を食べて美味しかったならば
人々を集めて いやあなた食べたご飯美味しくない
美味しくないと言ったっても何の意味もないでしょうに
これは 1万人の 10万人の人が来て
あなた食べたご飯は美味しくない
それは大きな誤差は自分で美味しかったんだから
ですから 瞑想して体験した人はもうこれは究極的なものだとか言ったったっても
言われてそこは他の人に何にも言うことできないんですね
たとえお釈迦様にしたっても
ですから お釈迦様が言うのはそういうことだから
自分がどんな境地に至ったかということは
ものすごく明確に観察してみなさいと
ですから 仏教の瞑想というのは
そういうサマーディ瞑想の世界では後観察ですか
そこはすごく大事にするんですね
なぜ大事にするかというと
そうすると客観的に冷静な心で
自分の今体験した経験はいかなるものでしたかということは冷静に見られるんですね
ああ良かった ああ良かったとか涙流しながら感情的になってもういろんなことを言うんじゃなくて
まあ良かったならば良かったと
幸福感を感じたならば幸福感を感じましたと
そこでその時は心はどういうふうに波を打っていたんですか？とかね
自分の煩悩やら欲やらどういうものは今ないんですか？とかね
まだあるというならば
どんな汚れがここに残っているんですか？とか
そういうふうにその状態は観察する
で パッキャウェッキャナっていうのは 5番目の訓練であって
それはとても大事なんですね
[背景音楽]アディッターナ・ウッターナ・アヴァシーッパッパ・パッチエク
そこはそういう枚数に 조사해ますけどね
で このお釈迦様はこのすごい自由な小さい時から物事を自由に考える性格でしたから
この先生にあなたが究極な境地に境地を体験しましたと言っても
ああそうですか それはありがとうございますとかね
そういう免許証をもらう状態の人ではなかったんですね
大体人間というのはすぐもう免許をもらいたがっちゃうんですね
それも無知の道であって
知恵の道じゃないんですね
私はあなたはすごい素晴らしく成長しているんですか？って
それは大きな嘘なんです
人は成長してなければ
それは人のことで 私はいちいち言う権利はないし
そこでその個人が誰かから免許証をもらいたがるならば
そこはすごく無知の道であって
それで自分が誤解するんですね
ですから 釈尊が悟り開く前から
あの この自分がどんな状態にあるのか
世界はどんな状態にあるかというのを客観的な観察っていうことはまあ透いてたんですね
ですから いろんな宗教のところに行って勉強なさったんだけど
そういうところに行って吸い込まれてね
それで一生もう終わって
もう歴史から消えるということはなかったんですね
それだったら歴史から完全に消えてしまっちゃいますから
お釈迦様が教えたものは
もう世の中でもう誰にも消すことはできない
もう力強く生きているんですね
それは真理を語ったんだ
それで来たのはやっぱりこの一番大事なポイントはこのパッチエクかなと
後で観察しなさいと で
私たちも普通の世界で
でも何か物事が起きたら
すぐもう感情的になっちゃって
必死になっちゃってわからないんですね
でも後で落ち着いて考えるとよく見えてくるでしょ
その時はこうすればよかったとか
ああだこうだとか もうなんだかんだで明確に見えてくる
感情的になって人と喋ったんだと
その時は自分が正しいと思っているんですね
でも冷静になって考えて
あ あんなこと言わなかった方が良かったんではないかと
よく正しく見えるんですね
ですから 知恵っていうのはいつでも後から出てくるもんなんですね
遅いんだけど その時は
遅いんだけど やっぱり知恵はもうこれ英語でもよく言うみたいんですね
なんか誰かすごい哲学者がね
まあ本当の知恵っていうのは
その物事をできた時が生まれるのは知恵であって
後でわかって で 世の中みんなそんなものでね
例えば政治をなさっている方々は
もう政権を取っていろいろ失敗したりするでしょうに
紅魔になったり もう暴言を話したりして
後で国民に嫌われて もう選挙に負けちゃうとか
負けたところで あんなこと言わなかった方が良かったとかね
あんな対策を取らなかったで後で思い出しますけどね
こういう風にやった方が良かったんではない
もう遅いでしょうね ですから
知恵っていうのはその場でやれば一番ありがたいんですけどね
でも 人間にはその瞬間ではなかなか生まれてこないということもあるんですね
感情的になりますから
ですから 禅定の場合も
瞑想 サマーディ瞑想の場合も
やっぱり後で観察するということを大事にする
それで間違いはないんですね
誤解はしない 一番誤解しやすい世界は瞑想の世界
なぜならば 普通には味わえないほどの喜悦
喜悦 喜悦感が味わうんですね
何にもしていないのに
その体からすごい喜びを味わっちゃうんですね
それで色界の場合は この喜びっていうのはものすごく体で味わうんです
単なる心で楽しいという状態だけでもないんです
で 体中 身体全体的にこの喜びの波が走り回っちゃうんですね
で 普通の脳細胞にはそう味わうことはできないんです
脳細胞と神経っていうのは苦痛を味わうようにできているんです
我々は楽しい楽しいと思っちゃいますけど
それはものすごい間違いであって
体の神経は痛みしか感じないんです
人間はよっぽど頭が悪いというか
体で楽しみ感じていると思ってるんです
楽しみは感じないんです
わずかに心で喜びをそうもなさんですか
この喜びというものは
心ではわずかには感じるんですけどね
体では感じないんです
体ではもう結構苦しみしか感じない
例えば肩が凝ったんだと
肩が凝ったら苦しみを感じる
それで誰かに押してもらうんですね
ああ 気持ちいい 気持ちいいって言うでしょ
押してもらうのどこが気持ちいいんですかね
ずっと体を押してもらってください
指圧していると痛いんですよ
単なるこの今ある痛みと違う痛み入れ替えてくれる
それで気持ちいいと人間が錯覚する
ですから体から痛みしか感じないんです
それですから 瞑想して禅定に入っちゃったら
体から幸福を感じ始めちゃうんですね
そういうことだから 禅定に入った人々っていうのは
それにとらわれるということはもうどうしようもないことなんです
とらわれて これこそ真理だと思うのはどうしようもないことなんですね
今 現代社会ではね そういうことを言っている人はいるんだけど
そんなにろくな瞑想進んでいるわけでもないんです
ほんのちょっと瞑想して
ちょっと集中力できただけで
これこそ真理だなんてこと威張ってますけどね
だから本当の禅定に入っている人っていうのはね,まあ見れば分かりますけどね
まあそれはそれで置いておいて
後で観察するということは大事であるということは覚えておいてください
そうすると どんな喜悦感を感じても
そこら辺の状態 どういう状態で感じたんですかということ分かるんですね
で 後で観察することで
もう一つのいい結果は
じゃあこれは究極ですか
これは最後ですかということも自分で後から聞けるんですね
自分で自分の心を質問できるんですね
私はもう 5分前禅定に入りましたと
その時はこういうこういう心の状態
体の状態 こういうこういう状態でした
心はこういうこういう状態でした
じゃあこれは究極ですかと
そういう究極だと決めつけることはできますか？と自分で聞くと
もしかするとさらに進めるのではないかという気持ちが生まれてくるんです
分かりやすく 例えば皆様方は国語を勉強するとする
それで古典語やら日本の初めの言葉から今の現代言葉からもう何から何まで勉強して
もうプロ中のプロになると
じゃあその一流の言語学者になった国語の言語学者になったところで
その人に聞いてみてください
あなたは日本語という言葉は究極的に勉強し終えたんですかと
聞いたら答えはどういう答えをしてくれるんですか？大体いえ
とんでもない 知っているところよりは知らない方が多いんだ
というのは当たり前なんですね
音楽にしたっても 例えば世界の一番になったピアニストがいるんだと
世界でその人はもう第1位
その人に聞くとする あなたはもうピアノというのはもうもう知り尽くしているんですかと
それ以上人間にはどう頑張っても
それ以上音楽を作ることも演奏することもできないと
あなたにはもう言えますかと
当然ながら答えは違いますよ
もっと練習すればもっと上手くなりますよということは大体心にあるんですね
ですから そういう一体感というものが生まれても
このパッチウェッカの足でそれで終わりますかと
自分で聞くと もうちょっと頑張ったら
もしかするともっと違う経験が得られるかもしれませんということが出てくるわけですね
そういうことで  2番目の戦場を励んでみる
3番目の戦場を励んでみる
4番目を励んでみると
5番目にも励んでみると
それで 5番目になったところで
心がすごい冷静で荒波の危機感がなくて
ただ至福感だけ残っていて
という状態になるんですね
そこまでは色界 そういう人々は亡くなったら天国には生まれません
人間の世界にも生まれません
なぜかというと 欲界には興味がないんです
欲界はもうくだらなくて苦しいだけではないかと
ですから 違う次元に生まれて生まれ変わる
それは梵天界ですね 仏教でいうと
だから興味がないということは本物なんですね
例えば私たちにとっても
やっぱり人間の世界はもう興味がない私にとか言うのは
あれ本物じゃないんです
別に経験があって言ってるわけじゃないんだから
ですから 普通の人はやっぱり私も死んじゃったら梵天に生まれ変わりますよと思っても
それは不可能なんです
本当にこの欲界はもうくだらないという体験を得なくちゃいけないんです
経験を得た人はもう人がもうあんた梵天に生まれないでくださいと頼んだっても
どうしようもない その人はもう経験あるんだからね
ひどい痛みにあったことはね
欲界では知ってるんだから
もうものすごい自然なエネルギーの流れで梵天界に生まれ変わっちゃうんですね
で 私たちはなんで簡単に天国に生まれ変われますかというと
人間の世界で欲がいっぱいある
食べて遊んで もう死ぬ時でももっと食べたい
もっと遊びたい もっと楽しみたいという
そこでやっぱり幸福な人は幸福を得られるんだという考え方もある
それだったら自分がいい行為をしてきたんだから
それだったら私はより幸福なところに生まれ変わるんではないかと
より幸福なところに生まれ変わりたいと
より楽しみたいって それも本物の希望なんですね
天国に行ってもすごい良い状態で
天女たちに囲まれてとかね
女性の男性の場合なんですけど
で そういう まあ天女たちも年は取らないし
すごい若々しくて 足の足の色をお釈迦様が言うんですね
鳩の足の色と似ているんだと
で 僕はそれ昔 いつでも鳩の足の色の天女たちとか
こういう決まり文句が出てくるんですね
僕にとっては 僕はニワトリやイロハ足みたいな
気持ち悪いんですね 鳥は綺麗だけど
足だけはすごい気持ち悪いんですね
なんで天女たちに鳩の足に例えてるんですかと
これ不思議で わざわざ鳩の足を見たんですよ
見てみたところで やっぱり綺麗です
鳥の他の鳥の足と違って
ものすごいピンク色なんです
すごいピンク色で あの
何て言いますか あの 鳥の足にギザギザみたいな
何て言いますか あのありますね
ケツメですか  いや 魚のウロコみたいなウロコみたいな
あれもものすごい綺麗に美しくすぎて
また色なんですね 色はもう不思議にピンク色なんです
ですから やっぱりそれは女人間に入れ替えてみると
人間の足もあれぐらいピンク色だったら
これは女性にとってはそれほど喜びないだろうと
足さえあれぐらい柔らかいピンク色だったら
体はもっと色美しいでしょうね
ですから そういう美しい体で生まれてくるんだと
天国に行ったらと言ったら
その場合はそこに行きたいなという気持ちが本物の気持ちなんですね
いわゆるこの世の中で味わう喜びを
さらにレベル高くして味わおうと
ですから 人間には天界に生まれ変わることはもうそれほど難しいことではなくて
とても簡単にできるものなんですね
いいことだけしておけば
天国には生まれ変わるんですね
で 梵天はまあ無理と梵天に行くためには
もうこの欲界はひどいもんだということを
何も楽しみがないんだと
ただ苦しみしか味わってないんではないかということを体験しなくちゃいけないんです
そうすると梵天に生まれ変わる
このいろんな宗教は全く同じだよという風に思う人は
もうものすごい無責任なことを言いますよ
私はそれをもう深く考えて
ちょっと反対するんだけど
結局私が悪者になっちゃうんですね
私はどれほどものを考えて喋っているかとは分かってないんだから
で 例えばこの全